quel notre invité en direct le
sociologue michel fize
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors tout d'abord un
première question important dispositif
policier pour ce défilé du 1er mai quel
regard portez-vous là dessus écoutez je
crois que cette date du 1er mai est une
date symbolique et elle est l'occasion
de faire ressurgir sur la scène toute
une série de questions qui n'ont pas été
résolues dont la question sociale
j'entendais benoît test parler du retour
de la question sociale
non c'est le retour médiatique de la
question sociale la question sociale n'a
pas été réglé les problèmes soulevés par
les gilets jaunes sont si je puis dire
un impact probablement plus nombreux
la situation de 2018 s'est aggravée
aujourd'hui il faut quand même savoir
qu'il ya plus de 10 millions de pauvres
1 millions de plus par rapport à l'année
précédente qui lie à un nombre de
précaires qu'on ne peut même pas estimé
tant que tant qu'il est important
et puis donc ce qui est encore une fois
problématique c'est que aujourd'hui
toute une série de population les jeunes
en particulier et les étudiants plus
encore sont frappés par une une
paupérisation qui était inconnu en 2018
alors qu'on dit souvent les riches
s'enrichissent et les pauvres
s'appauvrissent ans un peu la conclusion
de cette crise sanitaire est ce que le
gouvernement je parle du gouvernement
français en art vraiment conscience
écoutez je crois que gouvernement a
essayé de tenir la balance entre la
question sanitaire et la question
économique en essayant de ne pas
pénaliser le secteur économique
mais il faut reconnaître qu'il a quand
même largement négligé la question
sociale c'est à dire la question qui est
celle de la vie des petites gens dont
les filets jaunes sont les acteurs
emblématiques la société ces jo ni
depuis depuis deux ans je crois que
c'est pire aujourd'hui qu' il y a encore
une fois deux ou trois ans on peut dire
encore une fois que
aujourd'hui la france est en feu en feu
sanitaires ça s'appelle évidemment
lakovic 19 mai que derrière il ya
toujours eu ces questions sociales qui
sommeillait qui était quitté sous la
braise donc pas tant le défi c'est de
savoir si on va passer d'une france en
feu à une france à feu et à sang
c'est à dire une france qui pourrait se
réengager dans une lutte sociale de type
insurrectionnel comme c'était le cas
avec eux avec les gilet jaune donc le
mot de guerre civile doit être à nouveau
employé parce que c'est une menace qui
est que présente un parent rapport
évidemment à un pouvoir qui n'apportent
pas les satisfactions attendues
alors vous parliez adamo beaucoup
employé guerre civile un autre monde
beaucoup employé depuis plusieurs mois
la convergence des luttes
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on le voit ce
rassemblement du 1er mai gilet jaune les
syndicats des travailleurs est ce qu'on
n'y arrive à cette convergence des buts
à écouter les discours des uns et des
autres un certain nombre d'actions
notamment à gauche de convergence au
moins des points de vue de réunions des
différentes forces écologistes
socialiste progressiste et quelques
autres bons on peut avoir le sentiment
qu'elle prise de conscience que la
question présidentielle aura besoin face
à la candidate déclarée marine le pen
elle aura besoin d'un rassembleur aussi
bien d'ailleurs à gauche qu'à droite
donc la question est de savoir si par
exemple xavier bertrand peut être le
rassembleur des forces de droite et si
de l'autre côté monsieur mélenchon peut
être le rassembleur des forces de gauche
donc là évidemment on entre dans les
tractations politiques partisanes mais
je crois qu'il faut bien se dire que la
question d'une deuxième candidature d'
emmanuel macron est une question
sensible car de du résultat on peut
évidemment
craindre si par exemple il était battu
ce qui est quand même une hypothèse qui
est un joueur avance et on peut craindre
évidemment beaucoup de beaucoup de
perturbations dans cette société alors
l'actualité française et bienvenue dans
cette élection présidentielle dans
quelques mois puis c'est également le
covin 19
je voulais revient avec vous sur le plan
de déconfinement que nous a présenté
emmanuel macron à quel point c'est
important pour les français de
s'accrocher à une perspective oui je
pense que ce plan ce plan par étapes est
un plan est un plan intéressant
maintenant nous avons face à nous un
combattant redoutable qui s'adapte sous
la forme de variants qui se multiplient
au fil au fil du temps on ne compte plus
évidemment les variants sur la la scène
la scène politique
c'est peut-être la raison pour laquelle
quand je lis ou j'entends parler d'un
printemps chaud je pense que ce qui peut
se produire c'est un automne chaud si
évidemment d'ici là nous avons mis à
l'écart cet cette pandémie ce qui est
une hypothèse probable malheureusement
pas alex et à ce moment là il y aura un
réenchantement naturelles dont ce 1er
mai est l'exemple même leur et anchamps
le leur et enchaînements sur les
questions non traitées depuis depuis
trois ans les questions sociales qui
sont toujours dans ce pays considéré
comme des questions mineures
michel fize jean rappelle que vous êtes
sociologue merci d'avoir été en direct
avec nous sur rt france